on the throat
that part of the tube
is it uh
you said the design is not you could
have thought of maybe a little bit
better options because it's too
multi-functional is that
can you sort of elaborate on the
multifunctional nature of this part are
a lot of parts of the human body
multifunctional or do you find that more
specialization
is going to get the job done better
there is a lot of organs for instance do
have multiple functions you know the
pancreas is has two
it's like two organs in one one you know
secretes hormones like insulin into the
bloodstream and the other aspect of it
secretes uh digestive enzymes into the
gut to help you digest and absorb food
the liver is like 15 organs in one it's
just amazing how many different things
it does
but the throat you know so basically the
problem with the throat is as i said
we have two tubes that are right next to
each other in the throat one is for food
drink saliva mucus snot whatever you're
gonna swallow
all of that stuff must go down the
esophagus the food tube and end up in
the stomach and right next to the
esophagus millimeters away is the
windpipe or the trachea which goes down
to the lungs
and your your throat does these daily
gymnastics to
keep everything but air
out of the windpipe because you know you
slip up once and you can die
uh you can choke you know you laugh or
speak while eating and and it's curtains
unfortunately so it seems like you know
every aspect of the body when i was
learning about it in med school seems so
brilliant and so perfectly designed by
evolution or whoever you might think
designed it um to you know favor
survival to enhance life
uh but the throat seemed the opposite it
seemed set up almost for failure
and uh you know we developed all these
mechanisms as a compensation right we
have the gag reflex whenever food or
something is headed towards your
air pipe your windpipe or down to your
lungs your throat has this sort of like
rejection of it it pushes it away in a
gag reflex
at the same time we have a cough which
is something our body does when
something inappropriate does get down
the windpipe you know when we get a
little food down the wrong pipe uh we
end up coughing and the coughing does
usually flush it out and get rid of it
we even have something called the mucous
elevator in our lungs which is this
constant flow of mucus up the airways up
to the trachea dragging with it all
kinds of particulates that we've inhaled
and perhaps some food that went down the
wrong pipe and drags it up into the
throat and we swallow it
kind of unconsciously all day every day
is the truth even the mechanism of
swallowing is super complicated you know
uses a number of cranial nerves it uses
over 15 different muscles
um it's this coordinated act to keep
food out of the airway you know it you
can see someone's adam's apple and their
neck kind of jump upward when they
swallow
which helps lift the airway
up against this kind of the epiglottis
which plugs it closed and allows food or
swallowed drink to kind of skirt just
past it but every time we swallow those
things do come within millimeters of
going down the wrong pipe and it's just
thanks to these kind of compensations
these adaptations we have to the danger
of the throat that that keeps us alive
as i actually took a sip of uh water
it's kind of
it makes you
appreciate the wonderful machinery of it
all
uh by the way we have uh pulled up your
instagram that people should follow you
have a post about the throat
and then just showing so many different
components from the tongue
to the trachea the esophagus just the
entire machinery of it all
the teeth for the chewing
it's so interesting and so a lot of the
structure of this the anatomy
and the physiology does it echo other
mammals
are we so are we just basically
borrowing a lot of stuff from evolution
and maybe
making small adjustments maybe due to
the fact that we're not using our mouth
to murder
things as other predators might
we use our thumbs exactly we have hands
we don't need to bite them
um yeah there's a lot of overlap between
different animals which i find
very comforting and fascinating you know
someone asked me is there any animal in
which the throat is better designed and
i my first thought was whales because
the blowhole's kind of up on the top of
their heads i was thinking oh maybe
maybe they are set more separate but
when i looked into it actually no you
know the paths do come very close just
like in us and
uh i saw a paper about some new
discovered organ that actually helps
keep food and drink out of the airway in
wales that they hadn't ever noticed
before so it's a different mechanism but
the same kind of basic problem is that
you know where tubes and the air tube
and food tube are right next to each
other how well do we understand so just
even link your hand this little part is
there still some mysteries about the
complexity of the system because you
mentioned
just even for swallowing all these parts
in the brain that are responsible and
all all the different things that have
to like an orchestra play together do we
have a good sense from both a medical
perspective and a biology perspective or
is there still mysteries there's
definitely still mysteries we understand
a lot about for instance how the
swallowing mechanism you know is
coordinated it's
in the brain stem sometimes using some
higher levels of the brain
but it is a very thoughtless thing as
you mentioned when you drink the water
you know it's not something we have to
think about thankfully or we'd be
thinking about it all day
there's a lot we don't understand about
the basic mechanisms perhaps about how
the nerves fire and how they kind of you
know
coordinate on them on the microscopic
level how ions rush into and out of
nerve cells to kind of create that
electrical signal but
we sure understand a heck of a lot and
it's very fascinating
you